- It's just a crazy
fucking scene,
like, right out of
"Boogie Nights."
I mean,
there's porn going on,
and the porn
that porn people like
is really great shit,
you know?
It's, like,
"Wow, look at that.
That is really
a flexible midget."
[dark electronic music]
♪
[cheers and applause]
- Hello, everybody.
Welcome to
"This Is Not Happening."
I'm your host, Ari Shaffir,
and tonight,
it's all stories about romance.
[cheers and applause]
This first comic,
what an honor to introduce him.
He's absolutely hilarious,
a legend in stand-up comedy.
Please give it up
for my friend and yours,
Mr. Artie Lange,
everybody.
[cheers and applause]
- The next story also involves
this Rasta guy.
[laughter]
It's--look, I mean, I--look,
I would tell you stories
about my sister.
Not gonna be as exciting.
[laughter]
All right,
so this guy also told me to--
he took me to a couple
of the best parties
I've ever been to
in Los Angeles.
I tried to, you know,
find, like,
celebrity parties and stuff,
but this--
this coke dealer was unreal.
He took me to a couple
of the best parties--
not just LA--
I've ever been to in my life.
So this one party
he takes me to is,
all these porn people
were having a party
out in Woodland Hills, okay,
in this big fucking house.
These porn people
are having a pool party.
And we get there,
and we walk in,
and...listen.
It's just a crazy
fucking scene,
like, right out of
"Boogie Nights."
I mean,
there's porn going on,
and the porn
that porn people like
is really great shit,
you know?
It's, like, you know,
De Niro watching
his favorite movies,
you know?
It's like,
"Wow, look at that.
That is really
a flexible midget."
[laughter]
And...
[laughs]
So we walk in.
It's all this--
all this nutty shit.
We walk into a back room,
and I'm going there
because he's gonna go
get coke for us,
so I'm waiting for him.
We walk into a big room,
where there's basically
an orgy going on,
you know, and it's the closest
thing I've ever seen in my life.
A bunch of people are fucking
in a room, you know,
all over the place,
and I'm looking around like,
"Damn," and he goes,
"Yeah, man, enjoy yourself.
"I'll be back.
You know, I've gonna be--
you know,
do my shit for 20 minutes."
I'm like, "All right."
So I start looking around,
and I'm just watching, you know.
You know,
what am I gonna do?
Just, you know,
just push a guy aside
and start fucking?
[laughter]
[laughing]
"Move out of the way,
Erik Everhard.
I'm gonna..."
[laughter]
"Artie Lange's back
to do some work, motherfucker."
[laughter]
Could you imagine
a more disappointing switch
for that woman?
[laughter]
[laughs]
She goes from ecstasy
to bursting into tears.
[laughter]
So I look over to the left,
and there's a girl, like,
you know, a little older,
probably in her 40s.
You know, she's--you know,
she was probably a first-round
draft pick in 1984, you know?
Now she's got bad knees,
ready for a Hall of Fame speech.
[laughter]
[laughs]
But still looking good,
like, kept herself in shape.
And she's naked--naked--
on all fours, like, doggy-style,
on the couch looking at me,
and I'm looking at her.
And her face is sort of
leaning over the couch.
And I'm like, "Damn,"
you know, I'm looking at her,
and she goes...
All right, okay.
I walk over,
and I go right in front of her,
and I start rubbing her head,
and she's, like, you know,
doing, like,
this kitty cat thing,
and she was fucked up
on some kind of pills.
I don't know.
And she starts unzipping
my pants and taking, you know,
my pants down,
and I'm like, okay,
I'm not gonna stop this train.
And, I mean, I just--I just--
I got hard immediately.
I was never that horny
in my life.
This--I mean, I--
and I'm not a group sex guy.
This is one of the few times
this happened to me.
[laughter]
And, you know, 'cause I'm--
I don't--like,
these people dress hip;
they're cool people.
I look--you know,
I look like this.
I look like a gym teacher,
you know.
[laughter]
But I think she saw
who I was with or whatever.
I don't--I wasn't gonna ask
any questions.
So she starts to blow me,
starts, you know,
you know what blowing is,
sucking my dick, and...
[laughter]
For you younger guys.
I don't know what
the politically correct terms is
for sucking cock these days,
but anyway.
So she's blowing me, and I'm
having fun, like, or whatever.
Now, about a minute into this,
a guy who looks like The Rock,
okay,
comes over completely naked
and just gets behind her
and starts to fuck her
from behind.
Now I'm in a threesome
that I didn't ask to be in.
[laughter]
He just starts fucking her,
and he's, like, you know,
and she's blowing me,
he's fucking her,
and he's looking at me; I'm,
like, this far from the guy.
[laughter]
I'm a foot from The Rock,
basically,
and I'm like, you know,
what do you say?
"How you doing and everything?
I, uh..."
[laughter]
[laughs]
"You got any tips for how to act
in a thing like this?"
[laughter]
And it's just
very disconcerting.
It's odd;
I'm not, like--I mean, again,
I don't want to be--
I'm not homophobic or anything,
but--well, maybe I am;
I don't know, but, you know.
[laughter]
I mean, what--homophobia,
you know, what is "phobia"?
You're--it means you're afraid.
If you asked me,
"Art, are you afraid
of getting fucked in the ass?"
[laughter]
I'd have to say yes.
You know, I...
it might be my single biggest
fucking fear...
[laughter]
Getting fucked in the ass.
I'm also afraid of heights.
But I'd have to put
getting fucked in the ass
right up there with height.
They both have different things
that scare the shit out of me.
Like, with heights,
you're up high.
You're looking down.
You might fall.
And with getting fucked
in the ass,
you've got a cock
in your asshole.
[laughter]
So I just didn't want to get it
turned into that situation,
and I'm, like--he could
overpower me in two seconds,
so I'm just--
you know,
I have no shot at this guy
if there's a fight.
I'm looking around
for the Rasta guy, you know.
You know, he's probably fucking
five chicks in the back room.
I don't know.
So, you know, I start to recede
like a turtle, as they say.
I'm, like, you know,
I really--I was--
I lost my hard-on.
I'm like, "I can't do this."
And I said to him, you know,
"I'm done.
I don't want to do this."
So now as I'm trying
to pull out, she keeps,
you know,
trying to keep me in there.
Okay,
this guy was such a pro.
He takes his dick
out of her ass,
like you see in a porn, and
starts to jerk off on her back.
Now, I'm looking at this going,
"Whoa."
[laughter]
You know,
if the movie Clint Eastwood--
the Clint Eastwood movie
"In the Line of Fire"...
[laughter]
This is my version of it.
And I'm like, "What the fuck
is gonna happen here?"
So he starts to come
on her back,
and he's coming on her back,
and I'm like, "This is fine,"
and then he goes like this,
like, the last, like, "Uhh."
And a little speck--
a little speck
of The Rock's come...
[laughter]
Lands on this leather jack--
I had this $600 leather jacket
I bought.
It lands--
I see it coming at me.
It's, like, in slow motion,
like ehhh.....
like, in--I felt--you know,
I felt like Willem Dafoe
at the end of "Platoon,"
like, "Ahh!"
[laughter]
It just took its time,
ehh, ehh, ehh,
and just a little speck
lands right on my jacket--
my leather jacket.
And I'm like, "Oh, my God.
"This is the craziest,
worst thing
that's ever happened to me."
So I pulled out of this girl.
I ran--
I ran into the bathroom.
I tried to, like,
boil my jacket,
and I told--I made the mistake
on the way home
of telling the Rasta guy,
and again he was just so funny.
I said,
"But I think I burned it out."
And he goes, "Man, I'd--
I'd burn that motherfucker."
[laughter]
Dead serious,
and I said, "All right,"
so I got--
I threw the jacket out.
I threw my fucking $600--
$600 leather jacket
the fuck out
because The Rock came on it.
Other than that,
it was an amazing fucking party.
Thank you.
[dark electronic music]
♪